نحن نسمع عن
فيروسات أشعر بها الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى
أم أن لدينا المزيد من
المعلومات ونقوم بالإبلاغ عنها
بسبب الوباء
والاهتمام بما يحدث للفيروسات
والجدري وجميع أنواع الأمراض
الأخرى.  قليلًا من كليكما تعلمان
أن لدينا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي على الإنترنت
والتي تجعل المعلومات والأخبار
تنتشر بشكل أسرع ولكننا نعيش أيضًا
في وقت يزداد فيه السفر ، مما
يؤدي إلى زيادة التجارة
وزيادة تنقل
السكان وأيضًا تغير المناخ
الذي يتغير حقًا  كل من المشهد
الوبائي
والإيكولوجي الذي تعرفه
هو ما تعرفه ، كل هذه الأشياء
معًا تجعلها عاصفة مثالية
لانتشار الفيروسات ولكن أيضًا بالنسبة لنا
لفهم ما يحدث في جدول زمني أسرع بكثير ،
دعني أسألك عن جدري القرد نفسه
لأنه  هذا شيء لم يكن الكثير
منا على دراية به ، وقد سمعنا
عنه من قبل
ما هو عليه ،
لذا فإن جدري القرود هو مرض حيواني فيروسي حيواني.
مرض هو فيروس يعيش بشكل طبيعي
في الحيوانات ولكن يمكن أن ينتقل إلى البشر
ومرة ​​ولكن الآن جدري القردة ولكن بمجرد
دخوله إلى البشر
لديه القدرة على الانتشار من إنسان إلى
إنسان وهذا ما نراه أه
يحدث على مستوى العالم  الآن يزداد
انتشار البشر إلى البشر وهذا
شيء لم نعتد رؤيته في
الأيام الأولى عندما تعلم أنني كنت
أعمل على جدري القرد منذ عقدين في
جمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية وما رأيناه حقًا كان
مقدمة من حيوان  لإنسان
ولكن بعد ذلك فقط حالات قليلة أه حدثت
بعد تلك
المقدمة أريد أن أسألك عن
حالة شلل الأطفال هذه
إذا صدمنا لسماع أن
هناك حالة الآن في الولايات المتحدة
حيث شخص ما مصاب بشلل الأطفال وهو شيء
تم القضاء عليه  لعقود من الزمن ،
تعلم جيدًا أن شلل الأطفال كان
شيئًا لا يزال يغلي في
أجزاء من العالم وأه نحن
نستخدم مجموعة متنوعة من اللقاح الحي واللقاح المميت
، نستخدم اللقاح المقتول
هنا أه في  الولايات المتحدة ولكن
هذا كان نتيجة
لشخص قادم من
مكان آخر معه ، لكنك تعلم أن هذا يتكرر
مرة أخرى أن هناك عدوى إذا كان
ما أقوله دائمًا هو عدوى في
أي مكان يحتمل أن يكون عدوى في
كل مكان وفي عالم  زيادة
تجارة السفر العالمية أه
زادت من تنقل السكان ، لا يمكننا
أبدًا أن نقول حسنًا ، هذه الأشياء
تحدث في مكان آخر
ولن تحدث هنا ، ولهذا السبب
علينا مرة أخرى الاستثمار في
البنية التحتية للصحة العامة وسيكون الوعي بالأوضاع
أمرًا أساسيًا
لن نوقف ظهور الفيروسات ،
فلن نتوقف عن رؤية
حالة هنا أو حالة هناك من الفيروسات
التي ربما تم القضاء عليها هنا في
الولايات المتحدة ولكن إذا كان لدينا
وعي بالمواقف ، فيمكننا التصرف  بسرعة
ونفعل ما يتعين علينا القيام به لمنع استمرار
الانتشار